it is shocking video that has taken two
years to be released and led to
allegations of a cover-up
don't you turn over all right don't you
turn over
lay on your belly lay on your belly
yes sir
[Applause]
ronald green was stopped by police in
louisiana after a chase
following an alleged traffic violation
his family was told he died in a car
crash
instead he was tased beaten and left in
distress by officers for more than nine
minutes
they captured their quarry now i'm going
to
wash my hands now i'm going to check the
car out and search it
all those things sure you want to do
that but you really want to secure mr
green get them in a patrol car getting
sitting up
and then inquire about ems and their eta
to get there i saw it the first time
and i said this is this is premeditated
murder
when medical help finally arrived they
found mr green unresponsive he was
declared dead minutes
after reaching hospital the family says
the police
never mentioned the brutal arrest they
say there was clear evidence of a
cover-up
and the officers involved should now be
facing jail time
the video is probably one of the most
disturbing videos that i've seen of
police brutality
it invokes the image of what you might
imagine slave catchers look
when hunting down a runaway slave i
understand that the green family is
grieving
and any loss of life is tragic
regardless of how
i realize that there is a great concern
with regards
to the incident we share that concern
anytime the actions of our employees are
called into question
both state and federal enquiries are
underway there are reports federal
charges may follow in days
but there are growing calls for a wider
investigation of louisiana state police
itself
its lies its delays and its actions
alan fisher al jazeera